[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 206 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
i'm john and i'm here with my colleague
Gabby hey Gabby how's it going doing
John how are you pretty good just
getting over the Thanksgiving dinners
and regretting how much food I ate how
was your Thanksgiving how was your
holidays you know it was nice because I
got to rest
I got blessed week off and like I just
got all the days together but like I'm
tired of the weekend
I'm tired of resting which is weird but
it's good it's a good problem to have
right well it's not a bad problem to
have a lot of time to rest I barely got
the chance I was driving everywhere for
the holidays but uh glad to hear that
you had a great time resting on this
episode we're going to be talking to
developer advocate machine learning
engineer Zack akhil and learned for him
what you can do with ml and creativity
she's very creative when it comes to
building things from scratch by his
hands and you'll hear from him how he
takes a lot of inspiration from the
things he sees around him to build
really cool demos yeah he's very
passionate about that and it shows you
know it's really nice and we're also
gonna get into our question of the week
which is how to run cloud functions in a
local environment
so yeah I'll reply to that later but
learn how to use it without like I don't
know if your Internet's not working
maybe you need to do that so but before
that let's get into our cool things of
the week
[Applause]
we have now stocked driver on our Google
cloud code which is our extension for
Google or visual code and it can also
use on IntelliJ and what happens now you
can see the logs with our studio code
without having to go to the Google cloud
dashboard to see it and there is a link
there to see how to enable that on your
favorite IDE
pretty sure any type of extension that
Visual Studio code is so lightweight I
think a lot of developers tend to
gravitate towards that so it's pretty
cool very good performance usually so my
cool thing in a week comes from my
recent travels from Cube Khan right
before we did our workshop we released
version 0.8 of open match and 0.8 is
really focused around the developer
experience so there's a lot of getting
started guys a lot of tutorials and here
you'll see our documentation did they
really break down the most common use
cases and pretty much sample
applications that you can create using
open match so if you're interested in
creating a scalable match maker take a
look the other one is if you're familiar
with we call common theme expressions
it's a way to disturb queries and refer
in sub queries without having like
queries inside queries in Sai queries
the wif clause which you do that it's
now available on Khan spanner so you
will be able jawed to create a a sub
query and then reference on the next
query that you're creating without
having to copy and paste code which is
most cases not a good idea and be able
to create a priority table and execution
time to be able to process that
information for you so you gain
performance and more visibility on your
code that's gonna do it for our cool
things of the week let's go along and
talk to Zack and see what he has to say
about autumn a vision autumn a video and
the cool demos that he's been working on
[Music]
and on this episode we're going to be
talking to Zack Takeo a very very
interesting and very good friend of ours
that can you tell us about who you are
and what you do yes thank you very much
John I am a machine learning engineer
and developer advocate for the Google
cloud platform and what specifically do
you work on so my role and projects are
all focused around trying to inspire
developers to implement machine learning
into their projects what is a favored
machine learning tool that you have a
Google cloud platform that you recommend
that you like most the products that I
focus around are all the machine
learning api's and the machine learning
auto emelles which we like to call the
sort of building blocks a machine
learning that allows you to gain some
power and value from your data with like
necessarily needing to know all the
in-depth knowledge on machine learning
awesome
so we've mentioned a lot of the AI and
ML tools and Auto ml tools and our like
cool things of the week as they do like
product updates so can you give us your
definition of autumn ml vision autumn of
IDEO and best practices and maybe what
they're best used for most common use
case that I always tell people about is
if anyone's ever used google photos on
their phone or on their pixel where
they're able to search through their own
images based off of tags which they
themselves didn't put in so if you've
taken a picture of the beach you can
search for the word beach and it will
find from your own photos pictures of
beaches and that's actually a feature
that's built into the vision API so you
can upload any image and it will
automatically annotate it for you with
objects that are inside the image and I
can even do things like OCR or text
recognition within the image and we
commonly use that for if people just
have a large storage of images or videos
to you automatically annotate them to
make them easier to search 3 or to gain
some insight about what videos or
pictures people are uploading into
certain services that explains why when
we look at Google photos and if I search
for winter I can say snow or hoodies me
hoodies or with a beanie is that correct
yeah that's the kind of tags which will
appear when you search those sort of
things awesome
and that also explains why
it's so easy for me to find a lot of my
game images then I take screenshots of
hopefully and hopefully try to to
recreate later on when I'm practicing my
own exactly out with Auto ml vision what
is the most common Center is it
streaming or other kind of annotation
like Auto ml image what are the main use
cases were video is in video archive and
search there's a lot of times companies
especially companies that maybe have
their own kind of storage clients or are
storing a lot of videos things like
media companies they want to store the
videos and search through them quickly
without having to go through and
annotate them common use case that
someone came to me with recently was
with regards to video editing so
especially if people are recording sort
of niche video scenarios where they're
interviewing people and they maybe want
to get all the videos where people are
laughing that's not a feature that is
built into any API at the moment but it
is a feature that can be trained using
auto ml video so if you want a special
type of detection which detects when
people are laughing or maybe special
camera movements you can train your own
Auto ml to detect those so they will
automatically retrieve them when you
want to awesome so you really focus on
autumn of vision and video so when I
first met you Zack maybe earlier this
year you had a demo running on your desk
that if you place the item in front of a
camera to tell you whether or not the
actual item was healthy or not and I
think the sample did it you we're using
fruits and candy so it seems like you
have makers approach for all of the work
that you do and all of the demos that
you do so if you tell us a little bit
about how you come up with those ideas
absolutely it all goes back to when I
first got into tech and it was I got at
Arduino which was a like a small
prototyping electronics board for like
making projects to make LEDs and buttons
light up and that was my first intro
into programming and so when I started
learning using that I find it a lot more
rewarding seeing even just a single LED
light up compared to having some text on
the screen move in a different way so
since then I fell in love with making
physical things happen physical hardware
demos and then after university I looked
into machine learning and it was a lot
of
really cool machine learning
applications that were running on UIs
and desktops and exporting CSV files and
I really wanted to combine when you find
interest of machine learning with my old
passion of hardware and electronics so
now when I sort of come up with ideas I
was trying to combine machine learning
and embedded technologies just because I
think machine learning is one of the
most interesting new technologies that
people are getting into and hardware
electronics is one of the most fun ways
to interact with any kind of technology
so I just always try to combine the two
and they also created a demo that I
think you won a prize or something about
it with a bike and I'm al can you tell
us about more that absolutely so I've
recently one of my more recent projects
is a smart AI powered bicycle which
performs real-time image classification
of what's happening behind the cyclist
so as you're cycling down the road and
say a large truck is approaching from
behind your handlebars will light up red
to indicate there's danger and it will
light up on maybe the right-hand side of
your handlebars if your truck is on the
right-hand side and if the truck pulls
from the right to the left you'll see a
kind of blob of LEDs move across your
handlebars to represent the the truck
and I built this using the coral h TPU
which is one of Google's products for
running machine learning fast on
embedded systems and that plugs into a
Raspberry Pi and I built this and I
built it on to a physical bike and we
recently had an internal sort of
hackathon and in that hackathon it won
first prize as just like a hacky project
and quirky implementation of machine
learning but it's actually a project
which I plan to continue working on
until I can get kind of a more solid
working concept going and potentially
working with local bike companies in
London to see if we can get it onto real
bikes for people that's impressive I
would assume that you you're a cyclist
yourself and there's probably some
real-life inspiration behind this
project oh yeah absolutely there's like
some of the horror stories around being
heckled at
the road by like accidentally pulling in
front of people without seeing that
they're there but knowing that I
couldn't really do anything because I
because when you're cycling in London
I'm sure it's similar for other busy
cities like New York you really can't
turn round to check because you're
constantly having to look forward and
there's just like it's just like an
extreme sport is the way I always
classify it and the current technology
to help people be more aware on the road
hasn't really gotten past mirrors
they're ugly they don't run machine
learning so that's why I came up with
this that's awesome it's kind of funny
because in New York you get the opposite
it's the cyclist who how could you when
you're driving throughout the city the
funny thing is when I took this I built
this and I built a travel version of
this bike so like a flat-pack IKEA model
of a bicycle that I would take round and
assemble on stage to show people I took
it down to Sydney and I showed it to
people they all loved it because it's
Sydney's similar problem but they also
notified me of a specific like regional
problem to Australia which is for
cyclists the biggest danger is it
necessarily trucks or cars but actually
territorial birds that will sweep time
on cyclists yeah and it's a very very
common issue in Australia and in fact
it's very common to see cyclists cycle
round with zip ties tied to their
helmets to create like spiky hair to
scare away birds from attacking them and
yeah it's it's a crazy problem and the
initial version of the bike was just
using a off-the-shelf model that had
traffic detection but I was thinking of
sort of making an Australian version of
the bike that has a model trained in
Auto ml that has both traffic and
territorial birds so that it can detect
though there's there's a car there's a
car there's a truck and then there's a
falcon coming back what's cool is with
with Auto ml it's actually quite
straightforward because although amount
no supports exporting object detection
models to the coral HDPE so you have it
on your hand without having to connect
to the internet or rely on 4G exactly so
yeah
you can take a model that's trained in
the cloud on auto ml and just download
it to run locally on a July so you don't
need a connection to the internet for it
to work and about that you also
presented that demo cloud next London
yes yes it is how was the reception
I always start the talk by asking who
who in the room is a cyclist fortunately
it seems a lot of people in tech like
cycling because it's always the entire
room that raises their hand so they they
seem to really like it I always also ask
okay who cycles in London usually it's
about the same number of people if it's
a talk in London of course and then I'll
follow that up with okay who would
recommend cycling in London to like a
family member and then all the hands go
down so everyone's on the same page is
like we all cycling on and we all think
it's very very dangerous we wouldn't
want anyone to do it I show them the
bike they seem to really like it and
then people always come up afterwards
usually actually every time I've given
the talk there will be someone that
comes up afterwards who has an injury
that they got that week from cycling in
London and they but I really could have
used it this week so it really resonates
with a lot of people and then I do
remember when you were in New York you
were working on that image
classification matrix okay I was doing
like a little side project yes and it
was actually my first time doing an
image generation where you can get AI to
generate new images for you and I
actually I used tensorflow j/s on my
personal website Zak Akhil calm to
generate to generate the actual title of
the website in real time so as you're
moving your mouse around it's generating
the title like it's completely useless
doesn't solve any problems it's just it
was just a bit of fun that's how I have
fun is experiment with new AI beyond the
demos that you've built
I think you have a lot of interaction
with other developers to being a
developer advocate did someone else came
with you like with a really cool
interesting implementation from our ml
or the ml API is beyond that one that
you mentioned about the Laughing one
beyond that do you have any other
examples well
next san francisco's and it was a
lighting talk about giving a video and
using the video intelligence api and the
vision API automatically bleep out
anytime a person says an acronym and
immediately afterwards someone came up
to me and said that they wanted to use
this kind of technology using an auto ml
video model detect when someone is
talking about a specific subject like at
the time I think it was Game of Thrones
was still pretty hot and they wanted to
detect when say there was a video of
someone being interviewed and they gave
away a spoiler to Game of Thrones and
beep out when they say the spoiler hang
on a minute I thought Ned Stark was the
main character and then they jumped off
so they were gonna use old oil to build
a custom model to detect that so that
was pretty cool
they should did that for trailers - I
can't stand like oh yeah when you go
somewhere I don't watch trailers because
spoils for me they reveal everything and
like I want that everywhere that would
be perfect I feel like it's gone crazy
now with the amount of trailers I just
give away the whole film for free use
case for an Aldo Mel video detection
model so automatically trimmed down the
trailer to just like keep things
interesting so Zach I know that you're
quite the athlete I know that you play
rugby yes when you came to visit New
York you just randomly decided to go to
pick up dodgeball I tried to find a
referee but they didn't have it but I
settled for dodgeball so do you see
yourself using ml and like the sports
and recreational activities Rome or can
you tell us about some demos that you've
done in that space that's like
absolutely that was my original
inspiration to get into machine learning
it was actually to build automated
camera equipment for filming sort of
grassroots rugby matches because at like
school level I didn't play rugby
initially but I recorded the matches and
then when I started playing I really
wanted people to record my matches but
nobody wanted to do it because they
didn't want to stand out there in like
the Irish freezing weather holding the
camera steady where well my first ever
physical projects was actually a camera
that would automatically follow rugby
matches and record it I think I gave my
first ever talk at a PI data conference
about that demo and I'm continuously
anytime although ml releases a new
feature I'm always my first examples
of demos are always to do a sport or
sport tracking so I'm actually already
talking with some of the lead coaches of
the Great Britain tag rugby teams about
using Auto ml video tracking and things
like that in combination with drone
footage that's already been taking of
training sessions to try to say track
players and track their acceleration and
things like that and so yeah absolutely
I expect to see quite a few sport
related demos especially in summer time
not so much in the winter time sooo cold
except if it's curling like you could do
something for curling - that could be
nice like tracking the curls and stuff
it's not big I just like I said no one
came to my right I'm just perfect so
what is the demo that you're working on
now
well we've just finishing up all our
work on all most recent demo which was
in partnership with the Football
Association in here in the UK and it was
actually like the main demo of the next
London conference which involved three
camera phones or their actual pixel for
phones to record a penalty kick from a
full-size football or soccer net and it
would upload all the video footage to
the cloud using firestore and analyze
them with video intelligence and all
this stuff so that a person would go up
take three kicks and then it would
immediately see a dashboard with the
speed and accuracy along with the style
of their kick and get like their own
player profile card printed out for
their like sticker book oh that's
awesome
how long ago was the delay from the kick
to having the card from kick to card the
actual printer itself took like a minute
getting the kick with both the accuracy
power and the style calculations took
about 15 seconds conservatively
sometimes a person would forget to head
stop recording and it would take like a
half a minute but around 15 seconds to
get all the data continuously analyzed
and then into that like image is about
that 15 seconds impressive it's pretty
cool some kind of curious what MOS was
are using when it comes to like
following trajectories because I would
assume like if you're bending a ball
under a shot then there has to be some
way of try
the trajectory and then hopefully like
coming up with a more precise
calculation on I guess you can call it
with the style so the way we calculated
the accuracy this is probably the bit of
the project that I was most proud of
doing because what we did is we used
auto ml object detection and we just
wanted initially to track a football
moving across the screen and there's
already lots of public data sets that
have footballs and other sports balls
labeled and we actually use the public
cocoa dataset which you can download and
I actually took that and dumped it into
auto ml object detection scraping out
just the photos of balls and then
trained a model that would track the
soccer balls and that was the initial
model it performed all right until the
balls were kicked too fast because then
they'd stop looking like sharp soccer
balls and we're just like very smudges
across the screen and that's when we
actually just collected a bit more data
and labelled it in the autumn L UI which
is a good use case for slightly more
customized models because the the public
data set didn't have blurry soccer balls
after that it was performing like 99%
accuracy on tracking these class Beauty
objects and so then what we did to
calculate accuracy is we just recorded
someone taking a kick for each frame
detect where the ball is and then I have
a bit of a data science background so I
played around with visualizing maybe
like okay what's the speed of the ball
moving in pixels and what's the
trajectory of the ball moving in pixels
and eventually I stumbled across a way
of detecting
when the ball actually made impact was
the goal by continuously checking the
direction of the ball that it's moving
and then as soon as the direction
changed suddenly that was when it had an
impact with something and I would just
take that as the point of impact and
then we were also using auto ml to track
the targets that we had hanging in the
goal net and then once we know the
impact of the ball and the position of
the targets we just did like a little
distance metric and to calculate
accuracy that's really cool that you
found a workaround because I know that
when it comes to sports imaging they
typically use cameras that have like
really high refresh rates that way you
can
sure images really quickly but knowing
that ml can solve that issue with just
your standard I believe you said use
pixel for phones right we use pixel for
phones yeah cos we actually when we were
building the initial prototype we were
using my own like pixel to phone and
because most Android phones have a slow
motion capture of like 120 frames
minimum that was fast enough to capture
even people really like hammering these
like kicks and it was tracking them no
problem it's pretty awesome that's using
machine learning to do the heavy lifting
rather than getting more high end
technology I think the original spec of
the demo we were going to go for these
like high-end high speed cameras but my
kind of hackery nature was like no no I
just want to use a mobile phone because
it's simpler and more people have access
to mobile phones and rather than having
a model that detects a sharp soccer ball
will just train them all let's just exa
blury wonder it's fun way to think of a
developer man yeah did you have to think
that under pressure or like you had time
to do that I'm a notorious
procrastinator so to answer both
questions yes yes I had time and yes it
was also under pressure because I didn't
utilize my time as well as I could have
so I'm pretty sure you've had to take a
couple shot can you tell us a little bit
about your card I did check my car this
morning and I remember exactly the
scores
I got 91 on power I got 96 on style and
84 on accuracy Wow which was average
because we said a bare minimum it was
impossible to get a score below 50 on
any of the stats that's super impressive
man
I think in like everything over 80 was
good you know
so can you tell us about anything
interesting that developers using auto
mail for or maybe something that you
haven't your pipeline for demo is coming
up absolutely what I'm looking to do is
using auto melt video tracking to build
sports recognition technology so that we
can track players on pitches and work
out new tactics for players is there
anything that we missed that you like to
mention before we wrap things up the
only thing that's currently on the
horizon for me is using
detection exporting to HTP use for my
version 3 of my HTP bike where can
people find you like are you going to be
traveling anywhere can we expect some
cool demos that you're gonna like
open-source or maybe they can follow you
on your social media absolutely so i am
on twitter at zack akhil well you can
find me around in London I run a London
meetup group for people who are looking
to get into any kind of data science or
practical machine learning called
central London data science and yeah
Twitter and London no conference is
coming I'm gonna be a dev rock on I feel
there yeah yeah for sure
so Zak it's been an absolute pleasure
having you in this episode really
looking forward to seeing a lot more of
your cool demos and you know hopefully
we can hang out a little bit more when
you come back to New York City
absolutely Thank You Zach thank you so
much it's been a blast Thank You Zach
for talking to us and now we're gonna do
our question of the week John
so our question of the week is how to
run clown function in a local
environment so Gabby the cool thing
about serverless architecture is that
you don't need to worry about
infrastructure but sometimes you want to
test something without the point first
which is a good practice so you can now
use Google Cloud functions framework
which it is an extension for nodejs
where you can create a cloud function
locally and you serve your nodejs
application using Express and you can
hit the URL that you're just serving and
that's your called function locally
without having to connect necessarily to
the internet so it makes your testing
easier and you don't have to wait to the
poi like all the time that you do a
different thing on a function so I think
that's very useful awesome service
without the internet well it's not the
same thing we're like it kind of helps
like with small case scenarios you know
right so Gabby where are you going any
future travel to wrap up the end of the
year so no more work travel because
Conference seasons over finally I'm
going to with my family to Brazil so I'm
gonna stand the holidays there so it's
gonna be a family meeting which is nice
you I just wrapped up the last of my
conference travel and any other travel
that I'm having but what I will be doing
is going to a bunch of baby showers
everybody just decides that when I have
kids now so I will be attending a couple
baby showers one of them being my twin
brothers and at the wedding that we just
found out that they are having a boy was
he really excited about so yeah you kept
that secret for me I definitely did but
very excited for them and very excited
for all of my other friends who are you
know expecting kids that's cute
thank you all for listening to this
episode and we're gonna be back next
week I will see you later
see ya
[Music]